this sunday is family day here at
auradon prep
ready to discover a whole load of secret
siblings it's time to dig deep into the
descendants drawer of mystery family
members
hey disney you can't hide these vks and
aks any longer
who's ready for some wicked new
characters to be introduced in our dream
descendants 4 lineup
hi dad discover which secret sisters and
brothers didn't make it into the movies
but do exist in the wicked world
animated series
the school of secrets online shorts and
melissa de la cruz's novels when it
comes to villain kids and auradon kids
we can never get enough you sound just
like your mom
thank you mao's family history has been
an important part of the descendants
franchise so far
so it makes sense that the sentence 4
would introduce more of mao's relations
after all we got the big revelation in
d3 that hades is mao's dad
we also got a glimpse of his difficult
relationship with mal's mom maleficent
you abandoned me when i was a baby no
i left your mother so now the secret's
out about hades
that leaves the door wide open for his
son to join the lineup mal's
half-brother is called haiti
and he appears in melissa de la cruz's
novel return to the isle of the lost
it would be amazing to watch mal and
haiti explore the sibling link
in the novel haldi is a big fan of mao
he's one of the vks on the isle who's
inspired by mao's transformation in
auradon these vks decide to change their
villainous ways and form the anti-heroes
club we could also meet more of mao's
family in d4
in the same novel we meet star on the
tourney field herky who is hercules and
megura's son
as hades is hercules uncle that makes
mal and herky's first cousins once
removed
welcome we only get to see one of
captain hook's kids in the movies
but harry hook actually has two sisters
harriet is his big sis and cj is the
youngest
harriet appears briefly in the novels we
learned that she's captain of her own
pirate crew and that she wanted to leave
the aisle when the transfer applications
to auradon prep arrived she grabbed
forms for herself and the smee twins as
she was babysitting them that night
as for cj which stands for calista jane
she's the main antagonist in the wicked
world animated shorts
cj hey mousy miss me
decidedly a vk she causes trouble for
mel and the rest of the gang
like when she ties up ben and plots
against auradon we're villain kids
it's what we do how fun would it be to
see harry
harriet and cj all together in d4 they
could argue over who should be captain
of the pirate crew
that is if um is willing to give up the
role now that she's good
i'd rather talk about you hmm funny and
a gentleman
uma's family is very much kept under
wraps in the descendants movies
we don't even get to see her mom just
their tentacles slithering towards uma
and her voice yelling at her daughter to
do the dishes these dishes ain't gonna
wash themselves
so we would love to see not only whoopi
goldberg make a proper appearance as
ursula and d4 but also more of uma's fam
who could they be well in the first
novel isle of the lost
we get a brief peek at the sea witches
they're mentioned leaning over their
violins as part of the junior orchestra
at dragon hall we aren't given any more
info about them which means they might
well be uma's secret sisters
fans are more convinced that they'd be
uma's cousins though either way
we'd love it if china and maclaine's
real life sisters sierra and lauren
played the sea witches
but lauren might be earmarked for
another character okay
freddy retract your claws but i just had
them
sharpened lauren mclean voiced freddie
faciliar in the second season of wicked
world
and freddie is celia faciliar's older
sister lauren also starred as freddie in
live-action neon lights ball special
so it'd be amazing if d4 brought freddy
into the films after all
they've already got the perfect actor
lined up for the role fun fact
chyna and mclean voiced freddie in the
first season of wicked world but she
went on to play uma in d2
so that's why her sister replaced her
some fans think that this real life
sibling link
drops a massive hint that the characters
are also sisters which would mean that
dr facilia is uma's dad
what do you think of that theory either
way it would be great to see freddie and
celia together in the fourth movie
sister dynamics can get pretty fraught
and that could create some very
watchable tension between the facilities
please
my mom taught me how to apply blush
before i could talk the school of secret
series also includes a possible relative
for evie
that's the web series of shorts where a
secret camera records auradon prep
students in the cafeteria as the
daughter of the evil queen
evie already has a stepsister snow white
but there's no reference made to this
sibling relationship in the films
and we hardly see snow white in the
movies either she gets a short cameo
reporting on ben's coronation in the
first film we see the villains watching
the event on their tv
and the evil queen throwing popcorn at
her great nemesis on the screen
while we don't have any proof that snow
white has a child in the descendants
universe
we do have a theory based on her career
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
so it makes sense that snow white's
daughter could be a reporter too and we
see a student journalist in the school
of secrets in the episode when the
secret camera is spying on a meeting
about the school's student web scene
will you guys hear about that girl who's
been posting secret camera videos
the editor could well be snow white's
daughter and that would make her evie's
step nice
wouldn't it be great if d4 explored
evie's family more we'd love to discover
who her father is and what other
siblings she might have
the actor who plays evie sophia carson
also wants to know
after the first film was released sophia
told just jared she started to wonder if
her character had any siblings
hey guys i'm lani my mom's mulan
we've got an ak with a secret sibling
now and that's lani
she's not mulan's only child in the
descendants universe lonnie has a big
brother called lee shang jr
also known as lil shang he appears in
the novel rise of the isle of the lost
as a recent graduate of auradon prep he
was working as an assistant roar coach
at the school during his gap year
that's a sport that's a mix of parkour
and fencing with swords
which jay lonnie and chad played in d2
lil shang's plan after that was to go
home to rule northern way
and launch his hip-hop career how fun
would that be to watch play out in the
fourth film
there's another reason we'd love to see
lil shang join the lineup in d4
and that's his history with jay he
helped jay with roar training before
tryouts
encouraging jay to practice with his
little sis lonnie so lil sheng could be
a helpful ally for everyone that ships
jay and lonnie
and guess what lil shang isn't the only
secret sibling that's named after his
father
[Music]
gill isn't gaston's only child he has
two brothers gill is the only one who
isn't named after his father
his twin bros are called gaston jr and
gaston iii
and they appear in the first two novels
we might have even gotten a glimpse of
them in the first movie
some eagle-eyed fans reckon we can see
the twins during the rotten to the core
dance number the vk with the furry hat
and the vk with the furry coat that code
could be a reference to gaston's great
enemy the beast
in the first novel the twins show their
kind side helping evie on her first day
at school
but by the second novel they are
committed villains and don't want to
change their ways
the twins refuse to join the anti-heroes
club and are in cahoots with the biggest
vks left on the isle
mad maddie ginny gothel and anthony
tremaine we'd love to see these two turn
up in d4 and try to get into evie's good
books once more
she could help them become good
i'm hungry of course we already have a
set of twins in the descendants movies
and that's squeaky and square meets me
did you know they have a secret sibling
too
in d3 we got to see their dad mr smee
captain hook's first mate in peter pan
there was no sign of sammy mr smee's
other son
he's the twins big brother and is
mentioned briefly in the isle of the
lost novel as a guest at mal's
hellraiser party
we gotta keep this quiet you sure you're
ready but there's an even more
interesting mention of the smee family
in the school of secrets web series
in the fifth episode an auradon prep
student reveals that his great uncle
smee
had a boat tethered off the coast in
auradon my great-uncle smith used to
keep his boat tethered off the coast
that would make sammy plus squeaky and
squirmy the student's first cousin once
removed
how interesting would it be to discover
why a prince in auradon is related
to a villain that lived on the isle of
the lost we'd definitely love sammy and
mr smee to explain all in d4
the four of us are living the dream here
and we finally get to share that
which secret sibling do you most want to
see in descendants 4
let us know in the comments and hit that
like button to let disney know you want
a 4th installment of the wicked
franchise
thanks for watching